gentlemen delighted to have you both
here and because you are both experts
you hadn't dais experts shall we say and
I'm playing the deed sexo we playing a
lot dude sex they have sex and my kind
of i desire officially today yes
gamespot's review is up adtran gave it 8
8 out of 10 thank you John Luke save my
ass and so I'm a huge deus ex van I
wasn't super into human Revolution I
didn't like the swing of it yeah and I
love the old Warren Spector one and I
like the sx to as well actually but for
whatever reason and I was looking
forward to my kind of ID because I feel
like I missed the boat in the first one
and it wasn't necessarily the game's
fault i just i was probably playing
something else or something sure and so
I guess see you first law John Luke what
have you made of it i watch your like
history with the franchise you finally
all game yeah I played the original huge
fan of that I kind of I like the sort of
immersive sim style games you know thief
and system shock and dishonored kind of
you know kind that legacy I didn't I
enjoyed human Revolution a lot i know i
never played an invisible war right i
don't care about that one at all uh it
was like wasn't that only on the xbox no
pc is all kind of play it it kind of
felt a little bit portage but anyway I
digress ya know so I played human
Revolution and I enjoyed it quite a bit
it didn't fully grab me like at the time
I think as I played on the console and I
remember being really frustrated about
the boss battles and cuz i play like a
non-lethal stealth run and then that's
sort of like the big thing people talk
about that game you come up on it and
it's like here's these guys now you have
to fight him yeah and you're like oh
wait to kill the bosses stealth wise so
they fixed that and this one okay just
not having boss battles great yeah well
do it just completely took him out yeah
which I'm sure is probably fine I think
they had a second edition of human
Revolution where they actually did add
more to the boss battles yeah they did
touch stuff a bunch of things and
actually to rectify that and but apart
from that sort of stuff how does the
gameplay does it feel I mean it's been a
long time it's been all ghosts 2011 was
when human revolution came out in five
years um I feel like I spent five years
it does and it was so I at the beginning
the game it has like a 12-minute recap
rise it just is like hey you want to
watch this 12 minute recap which is just
Adam Jensen like reading the wikipedia
entry for human revolution over like
footage which was good because I don't
remember anything that happened yeah and
I'll ask game like something about the
Illuminati well it seemed like the story
and that one was even not necessarily
the biggest like attachment right learn
it was kind of augments our bad raabe
some people don't like augments we hate
progress it was it was one of those
games where was so as a game knows less
about that and more about freedom of
movement in the environment and solving
puzzles in a way that you thought you
were you had outsmarted the game only to
find out that the game had expected you
why do that or giving you the option to
do that and that's kind of what was
unique about that game also it's like
one of the only games you can put your
gun away which right all day enough is
it's kind of cool so my kind of vitae
then how does it does it play similarly
to that is it does it reinvent the wheel
what we talked about so far mankind
divided feels exactly like they just
turn the page in the next chapter of the
same book I mean there's you know they
polished at the animations and they did
add some new abilities but you're still
spending most of your skill points
initially on the stuff that you already
know is you need like hacking jumping
breathing toxic gas and then and then
there's like early on this is not really
a spoiler they'd like you have to lock
out some mobility so they make you
choose which one do you want before
you've really had a chance to okay play
with all of them in max pretty early
yeah so well so what about the levels
themselves unless I get into like how
this game actually plays when or feels
were you playing is it the same sort of
things on the queer you're very much
like okay I can go in here all guns
blazing or maybe I can like hack this
this one door and get something
girlfriend or absolutely so yeah like
typically you'll go to an area and then
it's like oh there's a guard there he
won't let me in and then you look around
and I like all right I could jump up
that wall and you know get around that
way you can go through a vent you can
hack you can it's all its that's kind of
a thing is it's all the options that
were there in the last game are still
there and still kind of the same right
and so I feel like a problem that most
people run into with these games is you
get into a rhythm where you're like oh I
like the hacking so you always just hack
or use the van
you always use the same three augs and
there's always an offense yeah there's
always a van yeah so you kind of just do
the same thing and then get into this
rhythm and so it's less about it's sort
of like you get to a new room in your
media like all right where's the vent
there's the right gonna go in that vent
you're not ready problem solving you
just kind of like I don't know you're
doing what's comfortable to you i guess
that yeah pretty much good after finding
that particular predictable rhythm for
like a couple of levels i decided to
start knocking out anybody who's asked
me okay and the game got really
interesting all of a sudden really so
why because you were just forced to be
in combat scenarios that I think you can
you can't play the game kind of combat
wise right ma'am it is everything's
there in the game for you to do it and
the game oftentimes doesn't expect you
to do it so some hilarity can ensue like
you knocking a guard out running into a
closet closing the door then knocking
the next five guys how to open the
closet door I'm ending up with a guard
dog pile that's fine they contain but
they're still opening the guitar yeah
figured of that okay and but it's
interesting because I think you can also
knock out such characters you give you
side quests right so that's the
punishment for going gym knocking it
anyone yeah it looks from what I seen
and I haven't seen I haven't seen it
running in person or anything yet i was
i was interested on the preview stuff we
were doing the weeks prior to his launch
and the world itself looked pretty
interesting like detail levels and more
variety than was in human revolution in
terms of that like what do you two think
of that iron so far it's mostly been
city streets and i think john link went
all the way to the end and some sewer
sections that had some side quests which
were interesting I don't know like Dave
sex has always been a game where even
though you have a lot of options I
always still feel like I'm in a corridor
right yeah it doesn't have that
dishonored feel where you're kind of
seeing how far to the side of the map
you can get which at which I felt in
deus ex 1 and 2 you were doing a lot of
like that's what that game felt like
which is not and what I'd played of I
played like a little bit of human
Revolution affair yeah yeah human
evolution and that's what it felt like
if I like the blind that the blinders
Ron a little bit is this kinda same with
this one yeah definitely when you get
into the missions it is more of a
path for me the stuff i really like is
sort of the hub world right area on a
while realizes esta it's pretty good so
you like you're walking a lot of detail
a lot of characters um I would find
myself like you know you see random
people and they're having a conversation
that you can just over here and it took
a while before I felt like I started to
hear repeat stuck I so they recorded a
lot of dialogue there are a lot of
characters that I could engage in like a
full conversation with and it didn't
lead to a sidequest it didn't do
anything it was just there to build the
world and that was cool like that kind
of stuff if you just like poking around
and talking to people and yeah reading
creeping creeping on people read it'll
creep in their stuff it's pretty good at
that it's just wait it sits in sounds
like the biggest criticisms that you
guys have of it is that it's very
similar to human Revolution totally so
somebody who didn't really play a lot of
humor relation I feel like this is great
she could be great yeah no totally yeah
if you don't have that yeah if you
didn't play it you'll feel like this is
awesome like first time experiencing
this yeah but for me as someone who
really liked human Revolution but you
know this it's been five years right
yeah so I was kind of hoping that it
would do a little bit more to advance
just like mechanically and stuff like
that and it kind of doesn't so yeah
feels more the same yeah five years is a
long time and any game series for
especially for a first time sequel I
guess and also yeah on a larger level
I'm kind of over games or just a
kleptomaniac for the sake of kleptomania
right and you spend a lot of time
picking stuff up in these ones I don't
know what the next thing is I mean some
genius game developers probably gonna
have to come up with whatever the next
thing is but like you run through this
in mass effect in Deus Ex where you're
playing it's like a slightly moral
character depending on how you play them
and what you do most of time is break
into people's apartments and steal their
medicine right there bonus in light it
just doesn't really make it doesn't
you're like this cat burglar and it just
doesn't really like add to the story it
doesn't really make sense for you to be
doing this constantly totally like I
Adam Jensen cat burglar you know I know
yeah and I guess it sits like you know
I'm sure the developers of argue or you
don't have to do it but like when that's
one of the only things you can do
outside of walking
and I guess that's probably the way I
mean ammo management is always an issue
in this game so you're motivated to go
poke through people's drawers bright and
most of them a blitz and drug management
yes well the drugs don't even it's not
even like oh I have this drug now it
does a specific thing most of stuff you
pick up just gives you crafting parts
what's wrong is used to like just turns
to scrap yeah just turns into scrap
right you're so like kind of a creeper
on people's emails and listening to
conversations it sound like as well
there's a nurse you get to this area
where it's like a slum area really bad
you meet you talk to this nurse lady and
she just talks about like here's how
dire the situation is blah blah blah and
I was like oh man that sucks here I'll
give you some like you know health packs
and blah blah next thing I do is I go up
I find her apartment and I'm like all
right let's see what's on her computer
let's do this from her safe and like the
game doesn't be like you took that from
her safe I'm like yeah whatever man like
who cares looking good no consequences
at all that's amazing steal from the
poor give to the poor exactly it's good
chat thank you both so much for coming
on talking about Deus Ex man come kind
divided review up on gamespot com name
ate at a 10 yeah final thoughts you
recommend this but like caveat that it's
pretty similar yeah I would definitely
recommend it if you liked human
Revolution you're like yeah I could use
another one of those absolutely if
you've never played it I think you know
and you seem like this is the kind of
game I want to play I want to check out
I think it's absolutely worth checking
out exit if you were hoping for
something just like a little bit more
fresh it doesn't really give me that
unfortunately no John McHugh competed at
iron you have played a bunch of it but
haven't completed yet do you think
you're gonna go back in and completed
her I got sidetracked knocking out large
swath of people through the through the
world make your own fun yeah I'm always
like griefing games like this and just
seeing how far you can push it and i
think the combat run is typically
pushing it for a day sex game so we're
going to see how far I can take it
excellent alright murder some people
come back and tell us about it next time
awesome thank you so much for coming on